for some reason Mexican people and only
Mexican people have this sound that
comes out of us that can just discredit
anything you put in front of it it
doesn't matter what it is we can kill it
with that sound I just graduated from
college top of my class
loves me
fine I'll be a
Mexicans there we go all right yeah okay
are you Mexican sir yeah well somebody
check his papers but um
all right now that joke was over the
line and so are you but uh
I love Mexican we need you guys you guys
are hard working you shut the up
you go to work you great good food good
beer big big fan
big dick well hey
[Music]
prove it prove it let's yeah let's see
that churro baby
this lady she loves Mexican men I'm like
that must be so convenient you can just
go to Home Depot
pick them up they're waiting
like about 10 years ago I went on a
college trip to Tijuana Mexico
because that's just what a good American
college student would do
and the thing is walking into Mexico
from the US they don't check anything
there's just a big revolving door you
walk right in they don't they don't
check your ID it's easier to get into
Mexico than a Costco you just walk in
different story coming back from Mexico
to the U.S there's no more revolving
doors now it's a Concrete windowless
tunnel with guards with M16 machine guns
and I was super nervous being an
immigrant and all and my college buddy
Ian next to me he was like Jimmy don't
worry man just just tell the American
they let you ride through I'm like easy
for you to say
Ian
Ian walks up he gets through no prom I
walk up the first thing they ask me
they're like sir are you an American
citizen I was like yes
but I forgot one very minor detail that
I wasn't
foreign
I was still an immigrant on a green card
and I wasn't a full-on citizen yet next
thing you know I was detained in this 10
by 10 box and they started interrogating
me they're like sir why did you lie
about your American citizenship I was
like I'm so sorry I'm drunk and I really
wasn't trying to lie my friend in front
of me told me to tell you I was American
so that's just what I did it was a
knee-jerk reaction he was like well was
he American
I was like well his name is Ian so
probably
and then the officer was like sir you do
understand this is a very serious
offense we could Deport you for this I
was like Deport me I didn't even know
that was an option
what was I gonna do back in Hong Kong
restart my ping pong career
that has sailed man
so I was like sir please please don't
Deport me I'm just drunk stupid college
student I'm every bit American I can
recite you every single Jay-Z lyric if
you want me to
see football leagues if that's not
American I don't know what it is
and I got very lucky this is what he
said he was like look kid
you got lucky we're not going to deport
you today okay but just don't ever do
that again or we send you back to where
you came from
and this was Asian
that guy definitely watched a great wall
many times
it was a very sobering
still wasn't American nothing has
changed
I finally got my citizenship three years
ago and it's yeah
you don't have to clap my point is
nothing has changed
just because I got a new passport nobody
in any part of the world is going to
come up to me and be like hey look
there's an American
oh my God
no no no the first day I got my passport
I was feeling real patriotic so I went
to my local Hooters
Coors Light I was
World Cup it was USA versus Mexico and I
was like man I'm cheering for Team USA
I'm American finally and this old
Mexican dude came up to me he couldn't
really speak English and this is what he
said he was like amigo
amigo Mexico
Korea
tomorrow huh
Emily what the are you talking
about what are you trying to start world
war three or something
I'm not a Korean he managed to insult me
with the only three English words he
knew
so I really felt the need to explain
myself I was like sir I'm I'm not I'm
not Korean I'm Chinese and they look
back to his friends he's like oh
I'm like sir you
that I can understand what that means
okay I have Mexican friends back home
just like you he was like no I'm not
Mexican I'm El Salvador I'm like oh
great now I'm the racist
but what like if you could get a slave
where would you get it from
that's a good question right oh yeah
yeah I mean I've thought about this a
lot
um my first instinct is Mexico
really yeah I just feel like they work
hard
yeah they could be out in the sun you
know what I mean they can't they did
shingles and then the bushes oh that's
true right they just do all kinds of
stuff you know they know how to do
everything bro
bro they can't be out in the sun okay
they have to be out there to survive you
ever notice that they always got
these specials about the pyramids in
Egypt they're like oh my God the
pyramids in Egypt who really built them
wasn't the Egyptians it wasn't the Jews
it was aliens aliens came down and they
built these pairs that's how you know
Mexicans are the best workers in history
there are also Pyramids in Mexico
nobody questions who built those
there is no hour-long History Channel
special who built the Pyramids in Mexico
Mexicans there was
a quinceanera needed attempt to have
that up by Saturday
aliens probably came and they're like we
got it you're gonna help that juice
that's okay over here everything taken
care of aliens
greatest workers in history only people
whose work ethic is a threat
the work ethic is a threat you ever hear
people say that about Mexicans
the Mexicans are stealing the jobs
how the you steal
a job
I've never seen a Mexican walk into a
restaurant give me an addition
do we do we have to give you the money
too do you want the money as well no rub
your gloves
I'll see you tomorrow at eight nobody
late
do we have to pay you more do we no you
pay me less money
consider this job stolen puto
stole it from you
major business economically viable
stalled it
I still did it from you
I wish they were still jobs every time
I'm in the Apple Store first of all if
you work at Apple Store you I don't
like you I don't like you right off the
bat I don't like it stop being so
condescending you're not better than me
fix my phone dork I don't want to hear
okay you're not better than me you just
didn't get in high school all
right that's the only difference fix the
phone
I wish four dimensions would raid that
place The Genius Bar is ours
watch these nerds squirm what are you
mixing stuff about selling Max
if we can sell oranges we can sell Apple
all right I gotta go
hello hi Elias uh hello
hello to you people over here
[Applause]
I'm just gonna do the whole show to you
yeah wouldn't it be awesome them
Olivia
hi you guys are kid
hi I'm gonna talk like this the whole
show is that okay
I just like to do a totally offensive
stereotype
of a Mexican
this is a Mexican at the border just let
me in
Jesus
they won't let us you guys are dicks in
there
you America
yeah
I don't know what he said
[Music]
it's a can stereotype hey Billy Bob
Borton
Borton oh look I'm boring you
you
uh I'm a 29 year old Mexican-American
tax accountant from San Diego oh you're
living in God's country
San Diego that's like La without the
traffic it's super chill
I love San Diego and your podcast helps
me plow through the endless amount of
Excel spreadsheets book to tax
reconciliation and procrastination
procrastinating clients that wait until
the last week of tax season to provide
their documentation isn't that something
then they just dumped it dirty dishwater
in your lap you're a saint wreaking
havoc to my mental sanity time and time
again but I digress
so I recently went to a friend's
birthday reunion
uh where she also invited a few people
that I had not had the pleasure of
meeting before everything was going nice
and dandy
went out of the blue
a mildly drunk blonde lady he said Dame
or a lady approached the table and sat
next to me to engage in a a seemingly
polite conversation oh
yeah what could go wrong here you're in
San Diego some beautiful blondes talking
to you you're being chill
you're not bringing any negative energy
towards yourself what could happen we
discussed what we did for a living
backgrounds and all the basic that basic
stuff as we were talking she began
inching closer
little by little reaching the point
where she casually rested her Palm on my
leg
as we were sitting talking
as you get closer and closer I sensed
the pageant whiff of tequila and vodka
that they were passing around to then
realize that she was pretty much
hammered
when arriving to this realization I
quickly disengaged
and moved over to some other friend's
table well aren't you a gentleman
as the night went up forward look at
this you did you did the right thing
you were raised right as the night went
forward one of my friends dropped a bowl
full of chips and I quickly reached over
for a broom to help clean up the mess
and oh no and out of nowhere the drunk
blonde chick appeared from behind and
aggressively took the broom off of my
hands and then yelled
oh no I will not keep alive the Mexican
cleaning guy stereotype let me take care
of it
oh God
oh my God
as soon as the words came out of her
mouth everyone in the room went went
silent
and I was the only one laughing I
actually thought it was funny
I can see why there's a white person
it's embarrassing the moment she left
the party I had numerous people approach
me and apologized for her comment when I
truly did not see what was the big deal
up to the point you know it's white
guilt
it's white Guild because all of them
probably had Mexican people doing
something over their house
as they act like they're good parents
um I truly did not see what the big deal
was up to the point where all of these
people made me question myself if I
should have been offended or not no
that's up to you that's up to you but
you gotta understand the way the world
is now
we're all just like ah not the woke
douche
and you're also an accountant and she's
coming over just being like why should
the Mexican guy sweep up yeah that's a
little I can see why people weren't
comfortable he said I should I believe
we should all be able to Dish it and
take it at the same time people nowadays
find offense uh whenever being the butt
end of a joke is this one of those
situation
or was that not cool to say well if you
thought it was fine then I guess it's
fine but it's like you know it's also
not a Level Playing Field so you know I
don't know no matter I really feel like
as a white person no matter how you
react in that situation you got to be
wrong like how could you just let her
say that or then why did you feel the
need to apologize
uh looking forward to your take on this
thanks and go fornicate yourself
um I'll be honest with you
uh back in the day when I grew up that
is something that you would say and
everyone would it leeway actually
people would say would have said worse
than that
um
I'm not saying racial slurs but the
jokes would have been way more
the way the you know the way it used to
be uh
I'd say a nice Archie Bunker type of
thing I still love jokes like that but
when you get into a public place and
everybody has cameras and everybody's
just waiting to film somebody saying
something up
uh but no I don't think you're I mean
your reaction is your reaction so
I don't know what to tell you on that I
thought you were going to be like I
thought you were going to get upset so I
think I'm part of those I mean there's
no way I would have gone up to
you and apologized for
I mean I probably yelled something to
her ah go home you drunk I would
have said something like that
but
um
you know
there's a big pressure night now to be
to to be a white person and pretend like
you care that's all it is you know and
that's like minimal work
you know those white people could
actually be down at the border
protesting why those children are in
cages or they could just go up to you be
like oh my God my heart breaks for what
she just said to you I did my good one
they could walk away I don't
know
I don't live in that world sir
so I I don't I don't know what to
tell you uh all I can tell you
is I wish people brought you their tax
you know
you know not on April 13th or whatever
the it is that they do
you know rip the Band-Aid off
just bring it to him in February and in
March they'll get it done you're gonna
know what way you stand
with Uncle Sam and the bankers that
make him walk the block like a
old prostitute
uh there you go underrated overrated
underrated getting your taxes in and
done
and just letting them take take a bite
out of your ass or get your
refund whatever the you have coming
to you
getting that out of the way as opposed
to just waiting
to the last second
um it's definitely underrated all right
well that is the podcast everybody
I want to thank all you guys for
listening as always uh as always go
yourselves I want to thank you guys for
the fat shaming I love it I guess this
is where I can bond with this uh
Mexican-American guy here well I you
know where some people would find it
offensive I love it and I find
it motivating
um so keep the fat shame and coming but
I tell you you only got a couple weeks
left
okay because I looked at my body mass
index okay and it said when I get down
to 173 I will just be in shape
you know for some reason at my height
you can be 129 to 173. I don't know what
kind of bird bones you have or if you're
running behind the dumpster every five
seconds chewing and spitting
whatever the it is you're doing I
don't know how you get down to 129 that
might be for like women
you know certain wafey women
how come you could be 173 and a woman
can't I'm not saying that
Abigail I'm not saying that
I don't give a
it's your butt do whatever the
whatever weight do you think you look
good at do that
I don't give a it's not up to me to
make you feel good go yourself I'm
really yelling at somebody he wasn't
even there right now